le rêve c'était plus clair qu'un souvenir
et j'ai entendu le bruit des
lunes
tonitruantes brisant des boucliers et des épées sonnantes
et j'ai placé mes cheveux sur le
trône de fer
[Musique]
et tous les dragons ont rugi comme un seul
je considère la question urgente celle de
votre succession
qui d'autre aurait une prétention le
premier-né
renera aucune reine n'a jamais assis le
trône de fer
le roi a un héritier damon targaryen
je ne serai pas obligé de choisir entre mon
frère et ma fille
[Musique] la
succession sera contestée des
couteaux sortiront
[  Musique]
tu es le roi
ton devoir est de prendre une nouvelle épouse
j'ai décidé de nommer un nouvel héritier je suis
ta
guerre des cheveux
est un pied
pensez-vous que le royaume m'acceptera jamais
comme cette reine une femme
n'hériterait pas du fer  trône parce que c'est
l'ordre des choses
quand je serai reine je créerai un nouvel ordre
ta famille a des dragons
il y a des hommes puissants qui n'auraient jamais dû jouer
avec
[Musique]
si rhaenyra arrive au pouvoir elle peut
couper tout défi à sa success  sur
je dois hériter du trône de fer
elle me barrera la route